let's go numbers I hit somebody I can't
I hit somebody
I hope they was playing behind
oh yeah I gotcha it all started with
some friendly Twitter banter between two
49er wide receivers marquise Goodwin and
Pierre Garcon what followed was a
generous invitation from gamespot to
settle the score in Rainbow six siege
the Rainbow six free weekend lands on
August 16th and to celebrate Marquis and
Pierre will compete alongside a team of
siege community members and GameSpot
staff to determine who gets to claim the
ultimate bragging rights in the siege
arena
[Music]
it makes me a great competitor in the
NFL my will to win I love winning
hence the last name Goodwin I'm just a
winner at heart what makes me a great
competitor NFL is uh but I I hate losing
marques thinks he's a better gamer than
me it might be faster wave not a better
gamer than me I was born for this ice
running through my veins
hello hello
I started on Twitter one tweet after
another and then you know boom we end up
in the arena and this is where we find
out who the true champion is so I'm
ready to go let's train siege is a game
that's multi-dimensional no game is the
same every round is different there's so
many different characters operators to
pick in just the gameplay experience is
always evolving which is why it's
constantly fun to play yes I'm just so
glad that we got marquees I mean
marquise is a much better pick I feel
like he's much faster he's much smaller
so today I'm feeling pretty technical I
want to get off in the first 30 seconds
it's not necessarily about kill count
it's a team game so if we can get that
in our team we can understand that then
I think we're gonna pull the head of his
gun I would go with Ashe okay extremely
fast she can probably beat you in the
40-yard together bad for you okay here
and you're 5 foot 9 175 you're basically
the same size okay with all the operator
abilities destructions of the map it
just gives you it lends for a lot of
options ways to help play the enemy now
what you got to do is you got to get
your feet wet in some gameplay
that's that's the Brandenburger Oh can't
learn unless you buy it
the shield guys going in first are your
teammates starting down all right
[Laughter]
[Music]
let's don't become my favorite game I'm
getting a real good night come on front
of you or to the right oh good try good
try
hey it's all right man okay oh hey now
you're that you're the last line of
defense
they gotta get to everybody else to get
to you
one shot can kill you the previous games
that I play you couldn't get shot hiding
behind a wall or from the third level
down I think it's a thinking man's game
you know what you have to anticipate
your opponent Moos when Marquis is
trimming off leg playmaker on the field
he relies along his speed and his
agility I think he's an approach to game
very focused on agility and physical
kind of brute force type awake it our
pins on the day I might be a tank one
day and I just roll up on you just here
here farm i justit easily hide it
peeking apart like a quarterback good
[Applause]
here's much more creative wide receiver
he like relies on his thoughts it's like
that and seeing him develop throughout
the league he's kind of like been that
veteran that you can rely on on a third
down or a tough fight
I don't think you can get much more
competitive or tactical our team is team
shenanigans we're gonna be crafty we're
gonna have fun and we're just gonna be
better focused both these guys have been
training me all day now it's time to
flip the script and make sure they are
in shape for the championship round
photos take your time with it the most
kind of like your first date you don't
want to take it too bad just try to get
their endurance I'm gonna start them off
slow and then speed up pick it up good
job 100%
they're in training today I learned how
to be a Roley
[Music]
I don't think I can apply that winning
passion from planning in there fail to
playing games I know I can because I'm a
competitor I've competed my whole life
and it's just something that I do
I don't think and get any higher tell
your truth to conference over that I
have right now it's just amazing I
killed two guys in training probably
gotta be my team ambushing his whole
team thank you
our goal is to catch em all off guard
one by one or two by three well however
you'll be catching slippery this would
be his first time coming in second to
one of the guys in his receiving room so
when I walk away with a win today have
my chest out and I will let here know
every day that he came in second tune in
to part two to see team Garson Throwdown
with team Goodwyn in the siege arena
you